Hi, my name is Corinne. I'm a senior in Art andDesign and my MIT for the past half a year has
been this R&D Pub which is a pub in the Stata Center that's been abandoned for the last three
years, and I managed to convince dining and CSAIL to give me a key to the space so that I could
transform it into an art installation. So I've beencollecting e-waste from all over the school from
campus dumpsters and then I've collected around63 screens and I put them all together into a twenty-channel
video installation and this is going to
be open for the public for this spring semester
in the form of performances that take placetwice a week. This is just a tour of the space
[Music]
[Singing]